ladies I get smashed now this has been a
big week for Jada doesn't return for
season three and she celebrated a big
birthday I remember there was a time I
was the youngest in the room and now I'm
not but with age comes a lot of wisdom
and I'm happier now than I've ever been
as if a red-hot career handsome hubby
and two challenging kids weren't enough
to make Jada smile about turning 45 son
Jaden gifted her with a gold grill I
think as you get older you really get to
the point where you just don't care
anymore what people think I mean I'm at
the age now it's like this is me it's my
skin it's my face this is my body love
it or leave it
Jada is also loving being back on Gotham
as villain fish Mooney you're going to
make me an army so I can have this
sitting kneeling my feet getting back
into the character was so easy once you
put that wig on and put those nails on
fish's back
drop the gun and those fierce fish
mooney looks are now inspiring her
everyday fashions I will definitely put
some leather on some black leather real
quick
then don't motorcycle jacket we had done
you